I have to tell you this is real we both
work for the same company both work for
Turner and I've seen you at a few Turner
events and we always I always end up
hanging out with you for a while I hope
that's okay with you
I sense a connection with us why would
you giggle at that I don't use the
height yeah I don't know or we're both
very attractive
you were both perfect specimens what was
it that you said this last time it was I
believe you sort of snuck up behind me
and sort of breathed into my ear you
know with the two tallest people in the
business we belong together
you're making me sound like a creep I
didn't I didn't sneak up on you I didn't
know it was you what what do you mean
because I was back here other guys stop
perving out to you I approached you from
a distance I think you could see me
coming I did not come at you that way
I'm curious but we have we've gotten a
chance to get to know each other a
little bit of these events it's always
really fun hanging out with you
I was curious because I know that on the
show um Rizzoli Niles you are play a
tomboy I'm just I sometimes get the vibe
that you're kind of like that in real
life that you grew up as sort of a
tomboy is that how you see yourself I I
did I mean I don't I don't see myself
that way as much now but um you know in
trying to figure out Rizzoli I watched
guys I went and worked with the Homicide
Unit in Boston and it was Oliver I love
Boston fantastic I think they'd like a
massage yeah
[Applause]
we get we get a lot of Pro homicide fans
we're all in town for a convention no
but I'd you know it's outside of you
know going to crime scenes and seeing
all the horrible things I also you know
I studied men in a way that all of you
guys react with each other and the whole
thing is with the handshakes and the you
know you never know which one to do and
Alex what he mean with the things you
know with handshakes when you know you
go in you do all that and all that's
know occasionally we've had guests on
that you start to do that stuff and you
can see on camera I get confused and
then just start to cry guys do it
y'all okay well then the ones that do it
real men do it
say it the guys they know how to do it
they and they know like as they're going
in there's sessom each other out in
there and they know and it's gonna be a
thing with the point and the chest bump
and the stuff and then they're done I
don't think a lot of us are just fine I
don't I'm just I'm just telling that
this is what happens when the that's my
move you can't do it I have no idea what
I'm doing it's horrible too massive
failure but as Rizzoli I mean I can nail
it every time right that's part of the
character now you can you can channel it